from the riverside to the royals few
towns do tourism
like windsor pre-pandemic foreign
visitors flooded here
this summer it's been more than just the
drizzle keeping the attractions
you like to try half shopkins yeah
right opposite the castle the windsor
chocolate factory and cafe have felt
that drop in footfall
this is a small family business it's
been a struggle they say to stay open
having certain groups back is brilliant
news
american and european tourists was
basically what drove this business to
where it is right now
um as soon as americans see chocolate
and the ability to make their own
chocolate they go straight for it they
don't ask the price enough
the fully vaccinated from america and
most of europe can now come without
quarantine
that includes british expats with
foreign jabs in their arms
for many like max who lives in spain
with his girlfriend longed for reunions
will now be reality
is a tremendous relief i'm really
looking forward to getting back to
seeing my friends and
i guess celebrating with them for the
things that i the things that i missed
you know um i i'm
you know i regret that i've missed all
of these all these kind of like
life events yeah and i'm really looking
forward to
being able to do that with what i'm
going to do is going to take a swap
sample from me
it was welcome news 2 just up the road
at heathrow airport
they've already been trialling the new
checks but after a torrid 16 months
they say full turnaround will take more
this is a good start the next thing that
we need to see
is for the cost of testing to come down
the easiest way to do that is to replace
the pcr test that we all have to take
when we come back in
with a lateral flow test which cost
pennies compared to
the pcr test the new rules will require
passengers to show
their vaccine passports the problem is
there's no standardized system
as to what those actually look like in
the uk you can get a unique code
generated via
the nhs app but every country has a
different system
and places like america have no
centralized digital pass
at all it all means questions over how
these rules will be enforced
and travel still far from totally free
countries like america still has its own
bans
something the government hopes will
change soon we can't
change that on the other side but uh we
do expect that in time they'll
release that executive order which was
actually signed by the previous
president president
and bans in would travel there are those
who say this is too much too
soon it is a big change with wide
implications
but in places like this where another
summer seemed lost
risk and reward are all relative helen
anne smith sky news in windsor